hello and welcome to the new world
review i'm grand line waifu and
i am incredibly incredibly confused so
let's get into it because who knows
what's about to be unleashed we started
the episode with atero activating his
magical girl super heart power and
ended up i'll we'll get to where we
ended up okay so one of the things that
really hit me about the combat from
start to finish was the fact that we
were all pretty aware that natero wasn't
doing a great deal of damage right we
knew and yet netero kept doing the same
thing
over and over with the same kind of
consistency
and regularity and grim enjoyment we've
come to experience from komugi and the
intensity of the situation was
compounded by the constant reinforcement
of gratitude in many ways this episode
the last couple of episodes i guess when
a tarot breaking down
backwards into the worst possible person
he could be from the best possible
person
he could have been it's funny because so
much of the episode made the points that
i've been making
even more clearly than i've been trying
to make them natera went from fearing
that the hunters were going to be blamed
for something
which sure depending on what happens
next i'm not surprised
but he went through that but engaged
with meroem in order to essentially
create a diversion by being as
indefatigable as he could manage to be
i'm not even going to pretend to be able
to say the name of his many armed
creature but the image of meruem being
swatted out continuously was not lost on
me
the idea that natero the person they
most believed was capable of carrying
out the task
was being slapped at by giant golden
hands that was very clear and even when
he was hit it took
those thousands of hits to wear down his
joint wear them down it did though
the art style of this episode was quite
beautiful it jumped around
so much and we went from what i think a
traditional or more traditional art
styles in the beginning through to
scraped out sketches that almost break
reality
and i wouldn't be surprised if someone
told me a few of tagashi's original
sketches are in there with the
saturation pumped up a bit because some
of it
really was that fast it almost broke
with the medium to give us manga energy
and i appreciate it when art is
self-aware like that
so i am also grateful the relationship
between meruem and
natero was a fascinating one because it
highlighted the issue of ego and pride
mary noted repeatedly his respect for
natero and while at first he did it as a
way to show he was impressed and almost
from a stance of goodwill
it almost felt as though between the two
of them it was a fight to see who would
get the most frustrated by unrelenting
propriety
the respect offered by both was
cutthroat and as someone of british
origin i have to say it was
and that's where the voice acting came
in because there is a tone one can take
while saying
have a wonderful day that tells the
person you're addressing that their
first born child has been cursed their
plants will die
and they will drop the last scoop of ice
cream the cordiality was
delicious and i appreciated it all the
way up until natero's pride appeared out
of the shadows
unlike mary's attempt to make clear that
natera was respected being genuine at
first
natera did not like the idea that an
insect could match him in power the
gratitude he exhibited became more and
more grounded the longer things
continued and the more limbs he lost
by grounded i don't mean based on solid
fact and clear judgment i mean that it
came down from the heavens
floating down into the tomb was the
first stage of his eulogy
he noted his gratitude with one leg
missing his focus declined and we ended
up in his mind briefly
once he had clenched down so hard the
muscles stopped the bleeding which is
the most intense way of stopping blood
flow i've ever seen and
actually probably possibly very likely
would have had the opposite effect
because if you have so much blood flow
science says no anyway this was the
stage at which his pride overcame him
except he had the opposite reaction in
the last episode he basically called
himself the pinnacle of humanity
that he was bored and had gone from
learning about how other people attack
to learning how to offensively attack in
a righteous way
problem is that it became a
self-righteous way the major problem
with that is that meroem is right
humans have reached the end of their
evolutionary ability
and its ego that stands in the way the
strategic way to take out the ant was
not what natero did by comparison
meroem isn't safe from the flaws he
perceives he spent the entire episode
the entire few minutes worth of combat
deliberately putting his body through
paces
because he thought it was all a game and
that no one could beat him and that he'd
wear him down eventually
i don't know yet if he survived but
realistically i would be surprised if he
hasn't
barely his focus was on strategy and
play and i think that's much more what i
expected from the tarot than the holy
i saw when he was done for mary thought
he was playing with a tarot and being
gracious when natera was deliberately
trying i imagine to soften him
that said checkmate me and i'll show you
my zero hand
sounds a lot less impressive than attero
thinks it is in his head
oh one thing to note was how incredibly
surprised meroem got when natero stopped
his blood loss
by opening his blood vessels more
because if you look at the art that's
exactly what he does okay
the point to this was that mary got
surprised and i love that slight eye
open
because the character has been so
incredibly
surprised the point is that mary got
surprised and i love the slight eye open
because the character has been so
incredibly expressionless the whole time
that to see something
get through was great oh and the title
of my biography was in fact mentioned in
this episode waifu
gently enveloping the target with an
indiscriminate love just like the hungry
golden gratitude and its vomiting star
by the end of the episode the king was
cut and scraped in his skin
jacket torn but he was walking and
probably the worst bit for natera was
that he was still offering praise and
trying to be a kind victor
and in fact he does become a kind victor
he offers free range human options
free range human options
a lot of what mary said about ego
disrupting the bonds between ants
we've seen it human ego is remarkably
powerful and we know it's remarkably
because i've been remarking on it for
the last however long i've been talking
about this ah pouf's ego stopped him
rushing to mary's aid
pito's ego has them in some serious
trouble with gon and yupi's ego has him
galloping to the king's aid with enough
respect for his opponents that he didn't
kill them
none of these things are good ideas
evolutionarily but by removing the human
from the equation mary thinks things
will be solved so why kamugi
i'm sure we'll come back to that when
atero tells mary his name he seems
broken just for a moment he seems broken
and i feel like
that's him coming to terms with the idea
that it has to be the end for him
then in that final grounding when he
reaches
that tomb natero goes from being the
entertained
entertaining character playing
basketball with the kids in the first
arc to death
itself with that hellish mask of wise
glee
the almost buddha-like shape of the head
as he cackled showed us that when
gratitude failed him all that was left
was indiscriminate carnage
the pinnacle of human evolution i
suppose at least it looked pretty
otero's final hunt was for his own heart
and if that doesn't speak to something
deeply sad about this series i don't
know what does
let's cheer us episode 127.
i'm gonna say that 127 didn't make me
feel as pleased about the state of the
world and our incredibly evolutionary
methods as
i'd have liked before the intro credits
ran hearing meruem noting that it was
checkmate from the start was a really
nice note it's always interesting when
tagashi allows us to see the thoughts of
those in a position where they could be
about to die
and i really like how much it tells us
there's no regret in his voice just a
sort of
grudging admiration that goes even
further which i could imagine is even
worse for natero
because even in death natero has
essentially done what komugi did
proving that humans are a dangerously
versatile creature while also showing
the silhouette of his ability and the
gaping hole of death in his mouth which
was no less disconcerting the second
time i was exposed to it frankly
the human capacity for destruction while
simply watching their fate approach them
made me think both that we are or are
portrayed exactly as the cattle we are
while also being very specifically and
objectively working very hard to achieve
our own demise
by planting seeds of distrust and
annihilation how
are humans and ants different in asking
the question but suggesting natero may
have been thinking it
it leaves us open to the idea that he
wasn't thinking it at all he spent so
much energy on the idea of
loathing something different to him
which is how the roses existed in the
first place
having that seed of hatred planted
within himself makes a great deal of
sense in that context
thinking about it that way the
difference between ants and humans is
simply that right
that ants don't hide the fact that
they're going to use others and they
don't hate those attacking them
both natero and gone are excellent
examples of the human condition because
they show us just how much humans can
hate
well the ants simply want to survive
they don't hate humans
they need the food they need to evolve
it's all about curiosity
and growth and change not a stagnant
gripping of status
and as pouf transformed it's about
protecting that change and protecting
what's at the core of them
outside of the blooming rose we saw gon
decide to use pito's care of kamuki to
ensure compliance
and this is a situation where i agree
with knuckle
or not agree so much as understand the
reaction
knuckle comes from an environment where
this is probably the worst thing he's
ever experienced in his life
these boys have been both into a video
game of death and the hostages
of a troupe of mercenaries the
experiences they've had mean they now
think like their opponents when the bad
guys act like the good guys
how do you tell them apart which is this
entire arc in a nutshell i guess
cuba still believes that gone is
thinking of him he might be but i
strongly think kilo was hoping god's
thinking of him rather than knowing for
a fact that this
is the intention i don't think that
whoever killa thought gone is
is still in the building anymore i think
gone left when he saw pito
and this is a new character gone saying
that if pito held up the situation he
would kill kamuki
that wasn't a threat and pito knew it i
also think it's very smart that it
happened before the others walked in
the timing of that entire sequence was
really cleanly and cleverly carried out
and while i could see all of it
unfolding and why
i don't think the importance of it is
going to hit until whatever happens to
do
with kite happens i don't think gone
would have too much trouble killing pito
nor would he have trouble killing kamuki
not at this point saying i trust pito
takes us back to the moment gone had
around the campfire with uh the
chameleon
guy commitment meleone when he said
i trust you or i'll kill you that's now
his tagline and i do note that it's the
second time he said it because it's the
start of a pattern
if it comes up again it becomes to my
mind a value statement and that's a
serious indicator of our next villain
or at least for me returning to up the
unfolding of the end of the episode was
very carefully handled what we didn't
get to see clearly was meroem
yes there was half of him but these are
ants and we know that at least one ant
can wrap himself in a cocoon
i'll be sad if it turns out meroem's
really dead because i think there was
unfinished business between he and
komugi an unfinished business between he
and poof frankly
the sadness of these characters and
their shift from apathy to hatred as
they tried to find meroem is a
very powerful one it's almost as though
the rose has simply seeded
more roses kell surprise
and what a garden to live in i would
like to watch more but to do that i have
to end this review so that's it from me
if you enjoyed the thought garden i
carefully attended click here here and
here
don't forget to like share subscribe hit
a bell and i'll see you
next time